i got to get to a story that i care
about an unreasonable amount
it's the love triangle between
kanye
and kim kardashian
and pete skeet davidson
kanye and kim kardashian
were married
they have four children together
then
kim
wanted to dissolve the marriage kanye
didn't want to dissolve the marriage
kim started dating this guy this
not very good looking guy from saturday
night live who somehow has dated all of
the hottest women in the world and kanye
is in trouble now because he made a
music video in which he
would appear to be attacking
physically attacking pete davidson
the cameras watch the kids i stop taking
the credit custodial dad i bought the
house next door what you think the point
of really being rich for when you give
them everything they only want more
boujee and a ruler y'all need to do some
chores rich kids this ain't your mama
house climb on your brother's shoulders
get that top ramen out god send me from
that crash
just so i could beat pete davis
so you get the idea goes on and on and
he's got this little claymation figure
of of the man who took his wife from him
and he's you know sort of attacking the
little the little figure so kanye is in
hot water here they say this is wrong
you shouldn't threaten this man it's
terrible this is awful stuff and kanye
for his part he said look art is simply
therapy
just like this view art is protected as
freedom of speech art inspires and
simplifies the world art is not a proxy
for any ill or harm so he's saying look
this is just art
okay i'm making art i'm not this is not
a direct threat i'm not gonna go kill
pete davidson even though i said that
god saved me from the crash just so i
could beat pete davidson's
derriere
i i don't i don't really mean it it's
just art
and now
a lot of libs are rallying to pete
davidson's
side james gunn who is that uh
fairly creepy film director he said
quote for the record pete davidson is
one of the nicest sweetest guys i know a
truly generous tender and funny spirit
and he treats everyone around him with
respect
he stole a dude's wife he stole a dude's
wife with whom that dude has four
children
that's not very nice
that's not generous that's not
respectful that's not the right thing to
do
kim and kanye i don't even think they're
divorced yet and he's stole this man's
wife as this man is trying to put his
family back together that's not a good
thing to do this is why i care about the
story so much
i know i shouldn't hear that much about
kanye and kim kardashian but i do i do
because
it's just wrong you've got this
situation where
you've got a reality tv star and she's
married to this
sort of pop culture genius who is i
believe bipolar he's got some
psychological struggles that he deals
with
and but he's he also
converted to christianity he also is
just somewhat more conservative than
most people in his industry so a lot of
the things that kanye will say and do
that people call totally crazy
are actually just
normal behavior for a lot of americans
like when he said hey i like what
trump's doing i like i you know he puts
the maga hat on they say he's gone crazy
he's lost his mind uh you know half the
country
supported the maga hat buddy it's not
that's not evidence that you're
schizophrenic or something like that
okay it's just that the left
pathologizes any behavior that is in any
way conservative they've been doing this
for years lionel trilling once said many
decades ago that conservatism is nothing
more than a series of irritable mental
gestures okay so that's but but sure
kanye's got some problems
he's got some mental
sicknesses
what happened to
i kim
take thee kanye for my husband to have
him to hold in good times and bad and
sickness and in health unless that
sickness is a mental sickness in which
case see you later buddy sayonara sucker
i'm gonna go hang with the child from
saturday night live no
no man that's not how you do it
and the the reason the reason the story
really strikes home for me is we've got
plummeting marriage rates marriage as an
institution is collapsing we even
redefine marriage at this level of the
supreme court and that's not good a
society cannot survive without
a sensible definition of the family and
a strong family it can't do it the
family is the bedrock political
institution
and it's just so sick to see a man steal
this dude's wife and then the dude is
trying to get his wife back because
they've got four children together and
then the woman what did she say she said
she actually had a big spread in a
vogue or some popular magazine where she
said my 40s are about me i don't care
what other people want i'm just gonna do
what makes me feel good oh yeah that's
brave that's courageous scar your four
children that's a good idea keep your
four kids away from their daddy so that
you can
pursue your own interests yeah you know
well-behaved women seldom make history
how about you just do your duty how
about you just suck it up and yes your
husband is eccentric and maybe you're
more attracted to the the dirty looking
guy from saturday night live but tough
tough it out man you know it's not all
about you good grief right now head on
over to rockauto.com fill in knowles in
the how did you hear about us box why
would you spend
30 percent more
50 more 100 percent more
for the same
auto parts at the brick and mortar store
when you could just go to rockauto.com
rockauto.com has a super easy to
navigate website so simple even i can do
it it's a family business been serving
auto parts customers online for 20 years
saves you all that time you don't need
to drive to the store then you get out
and they pepper you with questions then
they go in the back to get the part they
don't have the part there's just too
many makes and models these days they
have to order it in you have to wait
it's all that time don't do it go to
rockauto.com no gimmicks no special save
28 percent at 2am no it's just always
reliably low prices the same prices for
pros and do-it-yourselfers
rockauto.com head on over there right
now see all the parts available for your
car or truck and then most importantly
write knowles k-n-w-l-e-s
in there how did you hear about his box
so they know that we sent you
i'm glad you like that clip now
hold up
ring the bell
subscribe
leave a comment maybe if you liked the
clip
make sure you get the notifications for
future videos also head on over to apple
podcast spotify stitcher wherever you
get your audio podcast subscribe to the
michael knowles show leave a five star
review we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you